You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很大的压力。每天阅读、在昏暗的灯光下工作、长时间盯着屏幕——这种情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛，甚至夜间驾驶也会导致视疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛负担很重。因此，通过定期的眼科检查来呵护它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行眼科检查，价格仅需 99 美元起，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段发现眼部和健康状况。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host. And suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time,
要查找您附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 Specsavers。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因地点而异。我们都有过这样的经历：突如其来的招待恐慌。比如当聚会终于从群聊变成现实，而你却自告奋勇要当东道主。突然间，你需要零食、饮料、蘸酱、杯子以及所有没人提前计划的派对必需品。有了 Instacart，你可以在最快 60 分钟内送达所有这些杂货。无需再跑腿。为每个人下一份快捷订单。这样，一切都能准时送达，
making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacart app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. Welcome back to our second drink of Did I Stutter? I wanted to kick us off, Jenna, because we got a lot of mail about this episode. Many people wrote in to say that the phrase, did I stutter, is offensive and should not be used. Some people said that while they could see a buffoon like Michael Scott using this phrase, they were surprised that Stanley used it. And it's the title of the episode. Yeah. I mean, I think that's all valid. Yeah. I do too. It's definitely an outdated phrase for sure. And, you know, it makes me think of something else from my childhood that people also used to do if you couldn't hear them.
让招待变得轻松，让你看起来一切尽在掌握。立即下载 Instacart 应用程序，在指定零售商处享受零加价优惠。费用和店内优惠排除条款适用。欢迎回到我们《Did I Stutter?》这一集的第二杯饮品。Jenna，我想由我来开启这个话题，因为我们收到了很多关于这一集的来信。许多人写信说，“Did I stutter”（我结巴了吗）这句话具有冒犯性，不应该使用。有些人说，虽然他们能想象迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）这种小丑会用这句话，但他们很惊讶斯坦利（Stanley）会用它。而且这还是这一集的标题。是的。我的意思是，我觉得这些观点都很合理。是的，我也这么认为。这绝对是一个过时的短语。而且，你知道，这让我想起了童年时期人们常做的另一件事，如果你听不清他们说话的话。
Like, if they said something and you said what. Okay. Right. Because that's what happens in the episode. Yeah. And then Stanley's like, did I stutter? Right. Another thing that someone might do is sort of like mimic the vocal pattern of a deaf person, like to mock you for not being able to hear them or whatever.
比如，如果他们说了什么，而你说“什么”。好的。对吧。因为这一集里发生的就是这样。是的。然后斯坦利说：“Did I stutter？”对吧。另一个人可能会做的事情是模仿聋人的发音方式，以此来嘲笑你听不清他们说话或类似的事情。
Right. Well, you know, my sister wears hearing aids. so did my grandfather and my aunt and uncle were deaf. And it always kind of like, I don't know, I didn't like it. Right. It's like it's making this, it's making a joke of making light of this. Yeah. I mean, it just, I don't know. But that is something that we have phased out as well now. And I'm glad we have. Yeah. And also good that we have phased out this phrase. Because I don't, I don't hear people say that anymore. I don't either. And I'm really glad everyone wrote in. Thank you guys.
对。嗯，你知道，我姐姐戴助听器。我祖父也戴，我的姑姑和叔叔是聋人。这总是让我觉得，我不知道，我不喜欢这样。对。这就像是在拿这件事开玩笑，轻描淡写。是的。我的意思是，这只是，我不知道。但这确实是我们现在已经淘汰的东西。我很高兴我们淘汰了它。是的。而且很高兴我们淘汰了这个短语。因为我，我再也没听过人们这么说了。我也没有。我真的很高兴大家写信来。谢谢你们。
Yeah, thank you. Well, listen, Brent Forrester and Leslie David Baker gave us some great behind-the-scenes details about this episode. But Angela, I believe you found more? I did. So here's the thing. I went digging into the candy bag alts for this one. And when we first broke down the episode, we talked about Michael's talking head at the very
是的，谢谢。好吧，听着，布伦特·福雷斯特（Brent Forrester）和莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）为我们提供了关于这一集的一些很棒的幕后细节。但是安吉拉（Angela），我相信你发现了更多？我确实发现了。事情是这样的。我深入挖掘了这一集的“糖果袋”备选台词。当我们第一次分析这一集时，我们谈到了迈克尔在这一集最
end of the episode. Mm-hmm. You know, him and Stanley, they've kind of come to some type of an agreement. And then Michael has this hilarious talking head where he does an impression. of Rodney Dangerfield. He actually does a bunch of impressions. Yes. And I shared that it wasn't in the shooting draft. Right. You found the shooting draft in your digital clutter, and you wondered if there'd been candy bag alts for that. Yeah. But this was before we had access to all the candy bag alts. Exactly. So, yes, there are a bunch of candy bag alts. So you were right. Your instincts were correct.
结尾处的谈话头（talking head）。嗯。你知道，他和斯坦利已经达成某种协议了。然后迈克尔有一个非常搞笑的谈话头，他模仿了罗德尼·丹杰菲尔德（Rodney Dangerfield）。他实际上模仿了好几个人。是的。我分享过那不在拍摄剧本里。对。你在你的数字杂物中找到了拍摄剧本，你想知道那里是否有“糖果袋”备选台词。是的。但在我们能接触到所有“糖果袋”备选台词之前。没错。所以，是的，有很多“糖果袋”备选台词。所以你是对的。你的直觉是正确的。
And I thought I'd read you one. Great. Okay. This one kind of made me sad. Oh, no. Okay. It's sad. Sad Michael? It's sad Michael. Michael says, I have a lot of friends and I have a lot of employees. And they're the same people, mostly. So if I lose an employee, I am also losing a friend. And I don't want to lose two friends. Oh, sad Michael. But yes, there were lots of candy bag alts. Most of them are along the same vein of like him just trying to perform for the camera. Yeah. I'm thinking he's really hilarious. But, yes. I thought that one was like, aw. Well, we also got a fun catch from Taylor in Vancouver, British Columbia. Taylor said, I noticed something. It's not an old tech alert per se, but it is a, quote, out-of-date thing, I suppose.
我想读给你听一个。太棒了。好的。这个让我有点难过。哦，不。好的。很伤心吗？是伤心的迈克尔。迈克尔说：“我有很多朋友，我有很多员工。他们基本上是同一群人。所以如果我失去了一名员工，我也失去了一位朋友。我不想失去两个朋友。”哦，伤心的迈克尔。但确实，有很多“糖果袋”备选台词。大多数都差不多，都是他试图在镜头前表演。是的。我觉得他真的很搞笑。但是，是的，我觉得那个听起来很让人心疼。好吧，我们还收到了来自不列颠哥伦比亚省温哥华市泰勒（Taylor）的一个有趣的发现。泰勒说：“我注意到了某件事。这本身不算是一个‘旧技术警报’，但我认为它是一件‘过时的事情’。”
When Kevin asks Pam to say, quote, those will be due back on Wednesday because she is wearing glasses, I noticed that I haven't had an actual person say when my library books are due back in so long. It's a machine that does the book checkouts now, at least at my library. That's so true. Yes, I volunteered at the library. You know, at the elementary school when my kids were little, this was a very coveted volunteer spot, by the way. There was only two parents that could volunteer, and I snagged one of the spots, and
当凯文（Kevin）让帕姆（Pam）说“那些书将在周三归还”，因为她戴着眼镜时，我注意到已经很久没有人亲口告诉我图书馆的书什么时候该还了。现在至少在我的图书馆里，是机器在办理借书手续。太对了。是的，我在图书馆做过志愿者。你知道，在我孩子小的时候在小学，顺便说一下，这是一个非常令人垂涎的志愿者岗位。只有两位家长可以做志愿者，我抢到了其中一个名额，而且
I coveted it. Matt, I believe you are the library volunteer at your kids' school. Is this correct? Oh, yeah. I've been waiting years to become the library volunteer. Oh, my gosh, Matt. It's such a big deal. Yeah, it's a good gig.
我非常渴望得到它。马特（Matt），我相信你是你孩子学校的图书馆志愿者。对吗？哦，是的。我等了好几年才成为图书馆志愿者。天哪，马特。这可是件大事。是的，这是个好差事。
So you have to pay your dues. You have to pay your dues. You have to kind of lobby for it. I didn't get it until fourth grade. I don't know about you. Well, I'm with my youngest and she's in kindergarten, but that took a few years of like, you know, campaigning with the older kids. So, yeah, no, I'm in now.
所以你必须付出努力。你必须付出努力。你得去游说争取。我直到四年级才得到这个机会。你呢？嗯，我最小的孩子还在上幼儿园，但这花了几年的时间，你知道，在照顾大孩子的同时进行竞选。所以，是的，我现在进去了。
You're in early. I went every Thursday and I was there for story time. And I also helped restock the books. And I would scan books in for kids when they came in to return something, you know? And it is. It's all, it has a little barcode. and you have like the little, you know, little zappy thing.
你进去得真早。我每周四都去，我在那里讲故事。我还帮忙重新整理书籍。当孩子们来还书时，我会帮他们扫描书籍，你知道？而且确实是这样。它有一个小条形码。你有一个小小的，你知道，小扫描仪。
What do you call it? But you wouldn't remind people when their books were due verbally? You get an email, lady. Oh. You get an email. So now these are kids in elementary school. So Matt, I don't know how you guys are doing it, but they would get an email from the libraries, you know,
你管它叫什么？但你不会口头提醒人们书什么时候该还吗？你会收到电子邮件的，女士。哦。你会收到电子邮件。所以现在这些是小学的孩子。所以马特，我不知道你们是怎么做的，但他们会收到来自图书馆的电子邮件，你知道，
at blah, blah, blah, library school, right? Mm-hmm. That would just say your child has a book that has been out for three months. It's on arachnids and it's due back. or something. I feel like Taylor in Vancouver is saying that there's not even a person there, that it's almost like a self-checkout like the grocery store. Well, this is at school. Yes. So, you know, kids need a person. But here's, I'm sure all of your notifications are you
在某某学校图书馆，对吧？嗯。上面只会说你的孩子有一本书已经借出三个月了。是关于蛛形纲动物的，该还了，或者类似的内容。我觉得温哥华的泰勒是说那里甚至没有人，就像杂货店的自助结账一样。嗯，这是在学校。是的。所以，你知道，孩子们需要一个人。但我敢肯定，你们所有的通知都是
know. I scan their card and it pops up. And if they have, I'm with the kindergander. So if they have two books at home, I say, sorry, Joshua, you can't check out a book this week. No? You have to sit down. You have to say no to the little kid. Oh, I love it. That's my little faces. That's my favorite part. Teaching them responsibility. Oh, my gosh. I was such a softie. I'd be like, okay, you're not supposed to check any more out. But I'm going to let you have this one, but your parents are going to get an email. I say it very kindly, but I do like, you know, yeah. I mean, that's part of the job. It might be why you secured the job, Matt. You can be the heavy. I also, Matt, oddly enjoyed restocking books. Did you, do you enjoy that? Did you have to, is that part of your job description? I prefer the scanning and beeping and interacting with the children. But it is kind of Zen. You learn the Dewey Deceible.
你知道的。我扫描他们的卡，它就会弹出来。如果他们家里有两本书，我会说：“抱歉，约书亚，你这周不能借书了。”不行吗？你得坐下。你得对小孩子说不。哦，我喜欢这个。那是我的小脸蛋。这是我最喜欢的部分。教导他们责任感。天哪。我真是个心软的人。我会说：“好吧，你不应该再借了。但我会让你借这一本，但你的父母会收到一封电子邮件。”我说话很客气，但我确实喜欢，你知道，是的。我的意思是，那是工作的一部分。这可能是你获得这份工作的原因，马特。你可以当那个“坏人”。马特，奇怪的是，我也喜欢重新整理书籍。你喜欢吗？这是你工作描述的一部分吗？我更喜欢扫描、发出哔哔声并与孩子们互动。但这确实有点禅意。你会学到杜威十进制分类法。
You do, and it took me a while. I'm like, oh, and then by the end, I had the layout of the library, and I knew where everything was. It was a very coveted job. I left that question. It kind of brought me right back. Well, listen, everybody, thank you for writing in. And now here's your second drink of this episode. Oh, and teaser, y'all. Jenna has a fantastic deep dive on Madlibs in this one. You won't want to miss. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatching. podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Ooh, Angela, we have a good episode today. It is so good. It's so simple, so wonderful, so much tension, conflict, little bit drama, it's all there and some laughs. It is called Did I Stutter? It is a little bit of trouble. It is a little bit of drama. It is a little bit of, it. It is a little bit of,
确实，这花了我一段时间。我心想，哦，最后，我对图书馆的布局了如指掌，我知道每样东西在哪里。这是一个非常令人垂涎的工作。我留下了那个问题。它让我回到了过去。好吧，听着，大家，谢谢你们写信来。现在是这一集的第二杯饮品。哦，还有个预告，各位。Jenna 在这一集里对“疯狂填词”（Madlibs）进行了精彩的深度挖掘。你一定不想错过。我是 Jenna Fisher。我是 Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会分析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。哦，安吉拉，我们今天有一集好戏。真的太棒了。它如此简单，如此美妙，充满了张力、冲突、一点点戏剧性，应有尽有，还有一些笑声。它叫《Did I Stutter?》。这有点麻烦。这有点戏剧性。这有点，它。这有点，
is Season 4, Episode 16, written by Brent Forrester and Justin Spitzer, and directed by Randall Einhorn. We've got a lot to cover. I say get into that summary, lady. Here it is. Stanley challenges Michael's authority during a conference room meeting, leaving Michael's speechless. Later, Michael responds to Stanley's insubordination by attempting to scare him into an attitude adjustment with a fake firing. What is with Michael in the fake firings? I don't know. He thinks it's like a go-to. I mean, it did not go well with Pam. No, he should have abandoned this whole idea back then. Yeah. But he's still doing it. Meanwhile, Dwight decides to buy Andy's car at a discount only to immediately flip it for more money.
是第四季第 16 集，由布伦特·福雷斯特和贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩（Randall Einhorn）执导。我们要讲的内容很多。我说，开始总结吧，女士。在这里。斯坦利在会议室会议期间挑战了迈克尔的权威，让迈克尔哑口无言。后来，迈克尔试图通过假装解雇来吓唬斯坦利，以纠正他的态度，从而回应斯坦利的抗命。迈克尔的假解雇是怎么回事？我不知道。他认为这是他的杀手锏。我的意思是，这对帕姆来说效果并不好。不，他当时就应该放弃这个想法。是的。但他还在做。与此同时，德怀特（Dwight）决定以折扣价买下安迪（Andy）的车，然后立即转手以赚取更多钱。
Mm-hmm. So shrewd. Did he shrewd it? He shrewd it. Pam has to deal with the unexpected inconvenience of wearing her backup glasses to work after spending the night at a friend's house. Her backup glasses from junior high? Perhaps. I'll have a lot to share about that. I bet, I bet. All right, fast fact number one, we're going to talk a little bit about the inspiration for this episode.
嗯。真精明。他精明吗？他很精明。帕姆在朋友家过夜后，不得不处理戴备用眼镜上班带来的意外不便。她初中的备用眼镜？也许吧。关于这一点，我有很多要分享的。我敢打赌，我敢打赌。好了，第一个快速事实，我们要谈谈这一集的灵感来源。
We had a fan question from Bianca O and Katie W. They wanted to know who came up with the idea for Stanley to sass Michael. It was me. No, I'm kidding. Well, Angela, you do love a sass. I love the sass. Well, we traded messages with writer Brent Forrester about this episode, and he told us he remembered being very excited when Greg assigned them the script
我们收到了来自比安卡·O（Bianca O）和凯蒂·W（Katie W）的粉丝提问。他们想知道是谁想出了让斯坦利对迈克尔无礼的点子。是我。不，开玩笑的。好吧，安吉拉，你确实喜欢无礼。我喜欢这种无礼。好吧，我们和编剧布伦特·福雷斯特就这一集交换了信息，他告诉我们，当格雷格（Greg）把剧本分配给他们时，他记得非常兴奋，
because it was the biggest Stanley story he had ever done at that point. It was really the first time that Stanley had ever done. ever been the sole antagonist in a Michael's story. I remember we were all so excited for Leslie, just as actors, to be able to have that big moment with Michael and to go head to head with Steve, that was like, you hoped for that, right? Oh, yeah. This was huge.
因为这是他当时写过的最大的斯坦利故事。这确实是斯坦利第一次成为迈克尔故事中唯一的对手。我记得我们都为莱斯利感到非常兴奋，作为演员，能够与迈克尔有那个大时刻，并与史蒂夫（Steve）正面交锋，那是你所希望的，对吧？哦，是的。这太重要了。
Brent remembers Greg told him with great delight what the game of this episode was. It should be this. Michael is an overpowering boss to everyone in the office, but is totally unable to stand up to one person, Stanley. No one ever dares to challenge Michael this blatantly. So when Stanley snaps at him, Michael just has no playbook for dealing with it. He said that Mindy referred to this as reversal of status comedy. And it was the first time Brent had ever heard that term. Mindy, you're so smart. I know, right? I remember doing Comedia del Arte in theater school, Angela. No, here we go. Did you ever do comedia?
布伦特记得格雷格非常高兴地告诉他这一集的“游戏”是什么。应该是这样的：迈克尔对办公室里的每个人都是一个盛气凌人的老板，但完全无法应对一个人——斯坦利。没有人敢如此公然地挑战迈克尔。所以当斯坦利对他发火时，迈克尔根本没有应对的剧本。他说敏迪（Mindy）称之为“地位反转喜剧”。这是布伦特第一次听到这个词。敏迪，你太聪明了。我知道，对吧？我记得在戏剧学校做过即兴喜剧，安吉拉。不，我们要开始了。你做过即兴喜剧吗？
No, Jenna, I did my improv and my stand-up and my sketch comedy, so just let's hear it. Well, it's really very interesting because comedia dates back to long, long ago, and it is really all about status. And you're constantly switching status between these archetypal characters. And this has some real comedia elements for all you theater nerds out there, this reversal of status comedy. No, it's fantastic. I mean, even in improv, we would make someone, when you walk on stage two status, high or low.
不，Jenna，我做过即兴表演、单口相声和素描喜剧，所以让我们听听吧。嗯，这真的非常有趣，因为即兴喜剧可以追溯到很久很久以前，它确实完全是关于地位的。你不断地在这些原型角色之间切换地位。对于你们这些戏剧书呆子来说，这确实有一些真正的即兴喜剧元素，这种地位反转喜剧。不，这太棒了。我的意思是，即使在即兴表演中，当我们走上舞台时，我们也会让某人处于高地位或低地位。
And if you constantly played high status, because some people, it's their go-to in comedy, our teacher would make you reverse it and play low status. It was always a really cool exercise. Okay, getting a little nerdy. Okay, we can move on. No, I love that we're nerding out on status comedy. Guys, watch comedy shows and look for status and reversal of status.
如果你总是扮演高地位，因为有些人这是他们在喜剧中的首选，我们的老师会让你反转它并扮演低地位。这总是一个非常酷的练习。好吧，有点书呆子气了。好吧，我们可以继续。不，我喜欢我们对地位喜剧进行书呆子式的探讨。伙计们，看喜剧节目，寻找地位和地位反转。
That's your homework. We're making your television viewing homework now. You're welcome. We're giving you homework. Fast fact number two, Brent told us that this episode produced a mantra for the writer's room and a standard for which all episodes would now be held. What? Here were the three words that applied to this episode that they believed make a great office episode. Small, real, relatable.
这是你们的家庭作业。我们现在把你们的电视观看变成了家庭作业。不客气。我们给你们布置了作业。第二个快速事实，布伦特告诉我们，这一集为编剧室产生了一个口号，也是所有剧集现在都要遵循的标准。什么？以下是适用于这一集的三个词，他们认为这造就了一集伟大的《办公室》。小巧、真实、可感。
Brent said by normal TV standards, almost nothing happens in this episode. Stanley insults Michael. Michael doesn't know how to respond. He said on any other show, this would have been considered a totally insufficient plot for 30 minutes of TV. But he said at this point in the series, they were so confident in the characters and their dynamics that they fully committed to this very subtle interpersonal story. And they wrote this slogan in the writer's room, small, real, relatable. And he said that he believes that this is the signature of the office edit. it's best. I agree. I always love those types of episodes. I mean, I know it comes before this one,
布伦特说，按照正常的电视标准，这一集几乎什么都没发生。斯坦利侮辱了迈克尔。迈克尔不知道如何回应。他说在任何其他节目中，这都会被认为是一个完全不足以支撑 30 分钟电视节目的情节。但他说，在剧集的这个阶段，他们对角色和他们的动态非常有信心，以至于他们完全致力于这个非常微妙的人际关系故事。他们在编剧室写下了这个口号：小巧、真实、可感。他说他相信这是《办公室》处于最佳状态的标志。我同意。我总是喜欢那种类型的剧集。我的意思是，我知道它在这一集之前，
but I felt like health care was in that vein, you know? Yes. But yeah, I love small, real relatable. I love that kind of comedy. Mm-hmm. All right, fast fact number three, Angela, Pam's glasses. Oh, yeah. We got a lot of mail. Abby S and Amy G. want to know Jenna is your eyesight as bad as Pam's, and then Cat F, Jessica M, and Rachel G want to know how many pairs of glasses were given as options for this episode. I remember when we were filming this, at that time, you didn't need glasses. You had great eyesight. Yes, that's right. I did not wear glasses. I do now, but I didn't then. Those are totally fake glasses. Phil Shea came on over with his tray of frames, Greg was there, and we went through and I had to put them on, and we just talked about which ones did we like.
但我感觉《医疗保健》那一集也是那种风格，你知道吗？是的。但是，是的，我喜欢小巧、真实、可感。我喜欢那种喜剧。嗯。好了，第三个快速事实，安吉拉，帕姆的眼镜。哦，是的。我们收到了很多信。艾比·S（Abby S）和艾米·G（Amy G）想知道 Jenna，你的视力和帕姆一样差吗？然后凯特·F（Cat F）、杰西卡·M（Jessica M）和瑞秋·G（Rachel G）想知道这一集提供了多少副眼镜作为选择。我记得我们在拍摄这一集时，那时你不需要眼镜。你的视力很好。是的，没错。我不戴眼镜。我现在戴，但那时不戴。那些完全是假眼镜。菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）带着他的镜框托盘来了，格雷格也在那里，我们浏览了一遍，我不得不戴上它们，我们只是讨论了我们喜欢哪一个。
We did discuss, Angela, that these were frames that dated back to maybe, like, years for Pam. Like you said, are these her junior high glasses? Well, you said something interesting on the DVD commentary for this episode. You said you gave yourself your own little actor backstory, right, that didn't exist on the page, hadn't been discussed with the writers. and for you, these glasses were the pair that Pam leaves in the glove box of her car for just in case. Yes. Here's the crazy thing about these glasses.
我们确实讨论过，安吉拉，这些镜框可以追溯到帕姆的很多年前。就像你说的，这是她初中的眼镜吗？嗯，你在这一集的 DVD 评论中说了一些有趣的事情。你说你给了自己一个小小的演员背景故事，对吧？这在剧本里不存在，也没有和编剧讨论过。对你来说，这些眼镜是帕姆放在车里手套箱里以防万一的那一副。是的。关于这些眼镜，最疯狂的事情是，
Greg really, really wanted for my eyes to look super giant when I put on the glasses. But in order for that to be true, they would have had to put a true prescription in the lenses to magnify my eyes. And I said, but then I wouldn't be able to see all day. Right. But listen to what Greg said. Greg said, well, here's what we'll do. We'll give you contact lenses to degrade your vision and then correct your vision with the glasses. Greg, what?
格雷格真的、真的很想让我在戴上眼镜时眼睛看起来超级大。但要做到这一点，他们必须在镜片中加入真正的处方来放大我的眼睛。我说，但那样我整天都看不清东西了。对。但听听格雷格说了什么。格雷格说：“好吧，我们这样做。我们给你隐形眼镜来降低你的视力，然后用眼镜来矫正你的视力。”格雷格，什么？
And I said that sounds like a lot of effort for these few scenes where Pam wears her glasses. I've never worn contacts before. This sounds like it has the potential to be a real disaster. And possibly damaging to my future eyesight. So I told this to Lee as we were watching the episode. I said, can you believe that Greg wanted me to wear like contact lenses and then glasses? And Lee said, oh, that would have been funny. Greg was right.
我说这听起来对于帕姆戴眼镜的这几个场景来说太费劲了。我以前从没戴过隐形眼镜。这听起来有可能是一场真正的灾难。而且可能会损害我未来的视力。所以我告诉了李（Lee），当我们看这一集时。我说，你能相信格雷格想让我戴隐形眼镜然后又戴眼镜吗？李说：“哦，那会很有趣的。格雷格是对的。”
You should have done it. Oh, Lee. And I was like, oh, Greg will be so happy to hear that because everybody poohed this idea. Like props, hair and makeup, production. Everybody was like, Greg, the potential for mishap, with this idea is too great. We can't have it. So Greg was very reluctant to let it go, but he did. He was like, all right, fine, fine. So I think Greg would be really happy to know that my husband backs up his idea. Well, I have a few more tidbits about Pam's glasses, but I will sprinkle them into the episode,
你应该照做的。哦，李。我当时想，哦，格雷格听到这个会很高兴的，因为每个人都反对这个想法。比如道具组、发型和化妆组、制作组。每个人都说：“格雷格，这个想法发生事故的可能性太大了。我们不能这样做。”所以格雷格很不情愿地放弃了，但他还是放弃了。他说：“好吧，好吧。”所以我认为格雷格如果知道我丈夫支持他的想法会很高兴的。好吧，关于帕姆的眼镜我还有一些花絮，但我会把它们穿插到这一集中，
as we say, and that finalizes my fast facts, lady. Well, I have two things to share. First of all, little tidbit from the DVD commentary, Randall Einhorn, who directed this episode, said that the editor's assembly cut came in at 41 minutes. And then he took that 41 minutes and he got it down to 31 minutes for his director's cut. 31. He didn't want to lose any more. And they had to get it down to 22 minutes to air it on NBC. So there are a ton of deleted scenes. But in addition to that, there's all these other scenes that they didn't even get to put in the deleted scenes. There's more. Wow.
正如我们所说，这完成了我的快速事实，女士。好吧，我有两件事要分享。首先，来自 DVD 评论的一个小花絮，执导这一集的兰德尔·艾因霍恩说，剪辑师的初剪版时长为 41 分钟。然后他把那 41 分钟缩减到了 31 分钟作为他的导演剪辑版。31 分钟。他不想再删减了。而他们必须将其缩减到 22 分钟才能在 NBC 播出。所以有大量的删减片段。但除此之外，还有所有这些他们甚至没能放进删减片段的其他场景。还有更多。哇。
Yes. And Jenna, here's my big thing I wanted to share with you as I was prepping for the podcast. I found my shooting draft of Did I Stutter? What? I found the script. With all of those lost scenes? Yes. And some we actually shot.
是的。Jenna，这是我在准备播客时想和你分享的大事。我找到了我的《Did I Stutter?》拍摄剧本。什么？我找到了剧本。带着所有那些丢失的场景？是的。有些我们实际上拍了。
They're not even in the deleted scenes. They're out there somewhere. but I found my shooting draft and there are some really hilarious discrepancies that I am going to share with you. There is a Jim Pam moment that is going to make your mouth drop. But I am going to sprinkle these in. I'm so excited. I had my shooting draft. I am so jealous. I couldn't believe it. I can't wait. So now with that knowledge, I want you to know that we filmed this episode starting March 31st of 2008. We got an email from Kent Sabornack that said,
它们甚至不在删减片段里。它们在某个地方。但我找到了我的拍摄剧本，里面有一些非常搞笑的差异，我要和你分享。有一个吉姆（Jim）和帕姆的时刻会让你的下巴掉下来。但我会把这些穿插进去。我太兴奋了。我有我的拍摄剧本。我太嫉妒了。我简直不敢相信。我等不及了。所以有了这些知识，我想让你知道，我们从 2008 年 3 月 31 日开始拍摄这一集。我们收到了肯特·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornack）的一封电子邮件，上面写着：
hey, you guys, just so you know, while we're filming Did I Stutter, Canadian Entertainment Tonight is coming by the set to do interviews in the warehouse and they're going to get B-roll in the main bullpen. So we had Canadian E.T. Here, the week of Did I Stutter? Amazing.
“嘿，伙计们，告诉你们一声，在我们拍摄《Did I Stutter》期间，加拿大《娱乐今晚》（Entertainment Tonight）要来片场在仓库里进行采访，他们还要在主办公区拍摄花絮。”所以我们在《Did I Stutter》那一周有加拿大 ET。太棒了。
I love how you save every freaking email, Angela. It is so cool. and really paying off. I'm just a pack rat. I'm a digital pack rat and a real-life pack rat. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, we've got a lot of stuff. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
我喜欢你保存每一封该死的电子邮件的方式，安吉拉。这太酷了。而且真的很有回报。我只是个囤积狂。我是个数字囤积狂，也是现实生活中的囤积狂。好吧，让我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们有很多东西要讲。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。
Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still figuring it out. No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to, talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be
有时感觉好像其他人都把生活打理得井井有条。他们的爱情生活，无论是结婚、约会还是单身，好像他们都搞定了。但事实是，我认为我们都在摸索中。无论你处于浪漫旅程的哪个阶段，治疗都是一件很棒的事情，因为你有一个可以倾诉、寻求建议的人，可以帮助你确定你想要什么，并减轻你身上的一些压力。是的，也许还可以帮助解开过去的一些元素，这些元素可能
holding you back, well, BetterHelp therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp.com slash office ladies. All right, well, we are back. Michael burst into the bullpen with all of this excitement because, you guys, there is wet cement in the parking lot. And this is a lifelong dream of his.
在阻碍你。嗯，BetterHelp 的治疗师遵循严格的行为准则。他们在美国拥有完全的执照。BetterHelp 将为你提供治疗师匹配承诺。你填写一份简短的问卷，说明你的偏好，他们会为你匹配一个人。但你猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢他们，你可以随时更换不同的治疗师。BetterHelp 拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 获得 10% 的折扣。那是 betterhelp.com/officeladies。好了，我们回来了。迈克尔冲进办公区，带着所有的兴奋，因为，伙计们，停车场里有湿水泥。这是他一生的梦想。
He's got to do something, write something. What is he going to do? And Jenna, when I rewatch this, I started laughing because I remembered how hard Phyllis kept breaking. How hard we all kept breaking at Phyllis. Breaking. Yes, because she has an idea for Michael of what he could write in the cement. Mm-hmm. Oh, but she can't remember it.
他必须做点什么，写点什么。他要做什么？Jenna，当我重温这一集时，我开始笑，因为我记得菲利斯（Phyllis）一直笑场笑得有多厉害。我们所有人在菲利斯面前都笑场笑得有多厉害。笑场。是的，因为她对迈克尔有一个关于他可以在水泥上写什么的建议。嗯。哦，但她记不起来了。
What was it again? And Michael's going, come on, come on, come on, go, go, go. It's trying. and watching Phyllis trying not to laugh, like fighting it so hard, we were all cracking up. And if you go to 37 seconds, you can see Rain and John smiling really big because we had all just been laughing. Well, I just think it's very funny that last week, Michael got gum in his hair because he found something in the parking lot. And now, I mean, the cement. The parking lot has been a real source of excitement for him lately.
那是什么来着？迈克尔说：“快点，快点，快点，走，走，走。”她在努力。看着菲利斯努力不笑，就像在极力克制，我们都笑翻了。如果你看到 37 秒处，你可以看到雷恩（Rainn）和约翰（John）笑得很开心，因为我们刚才都在笑。好吧，我只是觉得很搞笑，上周，迈克尔因为在停车场发现了东西，头发里粘了口香糖。现在，我的意思是，水泥。停车场最近对他来说确实是一个兴奋的源泉。
And trouble. I kind of just want to say, Michael, get out of your car and go straight inside. Exactly. Somehow, Kelly suggests via Pam that Michael put his handprints. Pam translates Kelly. Yes. Pam speaks Kelly for Michael. But Jim won upst it and says you should put your face in the cement. Oh, ding, ding, ding, Michael is so excited. This is what's going to happen. And so much went into this one gag. Oh, yes. This simple sentence in the script was like a whole production. We got some fan questions from Anna V, Abby M, Sonia C, and Gabby C. Please give us all the details about this hilarious cold open. Did Steve really put his face in cement? How many times did he have to do it? Well, it was not actual cement.
还有麻烦。我只想说，迈克尔，下车直接进去吧。没错。不知何故，凯利（Kelly）通过帕姆建议迈克尔留下他的手印。帕姆为凯利翻译。是的。帕姆为迈克尔翻译凯利的话。但吉姆（Jim）更胜一筹，说你应该把脸印在水泥里。哦，叮叮叮，迈克尔太兴奋了。这就是要发生的事情。在这个简单的噱头上投入了太多。哦，是的。剧本里的这个简单句子就像整个制作一样。我们收到了一些来自安娜·V（Anna V）、艾比·M（Abby M）、索尼娅·C（Sonia C）和加比·C（Gabby C）的粉丝提问。请给我们关于这个搞笑冷开场的所有细节。史蒂夫真的把脸放进水泥里了吗？他不得不做多少次？好吧，那不是真正的水泥。
Kent Sabornack told me that they had an outside prop house make an organic mixture to look like cement. It was made out of water and some ground oatmeal and a few other ingredients to create a wet cement look. Jenna, I remember touching it and it kind of felt like a putty, squishy. Yeah. Kent said that we put that Vaseline all over Steve's face, partially so that we would have quick cleanup and we could do multiple takes. And guess what? It wasn't Vaseline. The container he's holding, says Vaseline. but Vaseline is too thick. So it was actually K-Y jelly.
肯特·萨博纳克告诉我，他们让外面的道具公司制作了一种看起来像水泥的有机混合物。它是由水、一些磨碎的燕麦片和其他几种成分制成的，以创造出湿水泥的外观。Jenna，我记得摸过它，它感觉像油灰，黏糊糊的。是的。肯特说，我们在史蒂夫的脸上涂满了凡士林，部分原因是为了让我们能快速清理，并且可以进行多次拍摄。你猜怎么着？那不是凡士林。他拿着的容器上写着凡士林。但凡士林太厚了。所以实际上是 K-Y 果冻。
I remember that. Yes. And then they saran wrapped Steve's head and put this like really big rubber band around it and then stuck a straw in there. Yeah. Guys, Steve is a trooper. Oh, yeah. Thankfully, Randallinehorn shares that we got this in one take.
我记得那个。是的。然后他们用保鲜膜包住史蒂夫的头，在上面套了一个非常大的橡皮筋，然后插了一根吸管进去。是的。伙计们，史蒂夫是个硬汉。哦，是的。谢天谢地，兰德尔·艾因霍恩分享说我们一次就拍成了。
So he only had to do that one time. And when Dwight says, force it in as deep as you can, Steve improvised. That's what she said. I remember that. And none of us laughed. Thank God. We couldn't. There was no way we were going to ruin that.
所以他只需要做那一次。当德怀特说：“尽可能深地把它按进去”时，史蒂夫即兴发挥了。“That's what she said。”我记得那个。我们谁也没笑。谢天谢地。我们不能。我们绝不可能毁了那个。
No. Steve had been like prepped forever with saran wrap on his head. We were not going to ruin that take for him. We all wanted it to be done in one take for him. Oh, yeah. Well, Jenna, at one minute, 35 seconds, we all help Michael up from the ground. And there was absolutely no way they could crop out my belly. And I am full pregnant in the shot.
不。史蒂夫的头上一直包着保鲜膜，准备了很久。我们绝不会为了他而毁掉那个镜头。我们都希望他能一次拍完。哦，是的。好吧，Jenna，在 1 分 35 秒处，我们都帮迈克尔从地上起来。他们绝对无法剪掉我的肚子。而且我在镜头里是完全怀孕的状态。
It is hilarious to me. I couldn't believe it. I laughed out loud when I saw it. There was just no way. It's a split second, but my big old belly is right there. Also, Angela, we have a fan catch from Yonina L. At one minute 26 seconds, she would like to know, are you covering your mouth to stop from laughing?
这对我来说太搞笑了。我简直不敢相信。当我看到它时，我大声笑了出来。根本没办法。那只是一瞬间，但我那大肚子就在那里。另外，安吉拉，我们有一个来自 Yonina L 的粉丝发现。在 1 分 26 秒处，她想知道，你是在捂着嘴防止笑出来吗？
She caught you. Probably. I knew I couldn't ruin this take. We got a laugh catch and a belly catch in one scene. Oh, yeah. Yeah, and one scene. Well, after he has placed his face in the cement, Michael has a wonderful talking head. And he just wants you to know that today wasn't just about him.
她抓到你了。可能吧。我知道我不能毁掉这个镜头。我们在一个场景中既有笑场发现，又有肚子发现。哦，是的。是的，在一个场景里。好吧，在他把脸放进水泥后，迈克尔有一个精彩的谈话头。他只是想让你知道，今天不仅仅是关于他。
It's about his grandkids, his great grandkids. They can come back in 100 years. And he can say, look, kids, your daddy left that face hole. And that's really the gift you want to give your kids and grandkids, right? It's a face hole. Yeah. Look, kids, at my face hole. All I could think about was the number of people who were going to trip in that face hole as they left the building.
这是关于他的孙子、曾孙。他们可以在 100 年后回来。他可以说：“看，孩子们，你们的爸爸留下了那个脸洞。”这确实是你想要给你的孩子和孙子们的礼物，对吧？一个脸洞。是的。看，孩子们，看我的脸洞。我能想到的只有那些在离开大楼时会被那个脸洞绊倒的人数。
It's just going to become like a rain puddle. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, now we're into the episode. Angela and Andy are doing madlibs. In the kitchen. Yeah. Angela is delighted to be spending this time with Andy.
它只会变成像雨水坑一样。是的。哦，迈克尔。好吧，现在我们进入这一集了。安吉拉和安迪（Andy）在厨房里做“疯狂填词”。是的。安吉拉很高兴能和安迪共度这段时光。
She's having the best time. Well, I think what we learn in the scene is that Angela loves a madlib. Who would have thought? I don't know if it necessarily is Andy that she's delighted by or just the idea of a Mablib. Maybe a little of both. Maybe. So I went to the script, Jenna.
她玩得很开心。好吧，我认为我们在这一场景中学到的是，安吉拉喜欢“疯狂填词”。谁会想到呢？我不知道她高兴是因为安迪，还是仅仅因为“疯狂填词”这个点子。也许两者都有。也许吧。所以我查了剧本，Jenna。
I went to my shooting draft to see if this scene was written the way we did it. It is up until one point and then there was an extra couplet that I remember us filming because Ed was so funny and I'm so bummed. It's not even in the deleted scenes on the DVD commentary and I'm going to share it with you. So in the episode, Andy reads the Madlib, and it reads, The Tall Man entered the Nice Building to visit a very nice man. Sit down, Mr. Smith. Could I interest you in any good cat food? And Angela says a man eating cat food.
我查了我的拍摄剧本，看看这一场景是否像我们做的那样写。直到某一点之前都是这样，然后还有一段额外的对联，我记得我们拍过，因为埃德（Ed）太搞笑了，我很沮丧。它甚至不在 DVD 评论的删减片段里，我要和你分享。所以在这一集里，安迪读了“疯狂填词”，上面写着：“高个子男人进入了漂亮的建筑去拜访一个非常好的男人。坐下，史密斯先生。我能用什么好猫粮来吸引你吗？”安吉拉说：“一个男人在吃猫粮。”
And Andy says a cat eating man food. And they giggle, right? Yeah. Well, the scene would have continued. Andy starts pantomiming being a cat, eating a hamburger. And he goes, meow, a burger. Ed was so funny doing this, Jenna. And then I would have responded, a cat eating a hamburger sandwich, that's impossible.
安迪说：“一只猫在吃人食。”他们咯咯笑，对吧？是的。好吧，场景本应继续。安迪开始模仿一只猫，吃着汉堡包。他说：“喵，一个汉堡。”埃德做这个动作太搞笑了，Jenna。然后我会回应：“一只猫在吃汉堡三明治，那是不可能的。”
And then Andy goes, I know. And I say, where do you think of these things? And we laugh. Amazing. A cat eating a hamburger sandwich. I'm really sad that you didn't get to hear that or see Ed pretending to be a cat eating a hamburger. Well, Angela, Justin told me. that Gene and Lee actually wrote this MADLib scene for Angela and Andy.
然后安迪说：“我知道。”我说：“你是怎么想到这些东西的？”然后我们笑了。太棒了。一只猫在吃汉堡三明治。我真的很伤心你没能听到或看到埃德假装成一只猫在吃汉堡。好吧，安吉拉，贾斯汀告诉我，吉恩（Gene）和李（Lee）实际上为安吉拉和安迪写了这个“疯狂填词”场景。
So all of that was Gene and Lee. Well, it was so fun to do. I became inspired by this scene, Angela, to do a deep dive on MadLibs. Oh, no. What'd you find? Oh, my God. It is fascinating. Well, our kids love MadLibs.
所以这一切都是吉恩和李写的。好吧，做起来太有趣了。我被这个场景启发了，安吉拉，去做一个关于“疯狂填词”的深度挖掘。哦，不。你发现了什么？哦，天哪。这太迷人了。好吧，我们的孩子喜欢“疯狂填词”。
I mean, Jenna, I did them growing up. We still do them. Same. Let me tell you the history of MadLibs. Okay. Madlibs was invented in 1953 by two men, Leonard Stern and Roger Price. Roger Price had worked as a writer on the Bob Hope Show. Leonard Stern was his friend who worked as a writer on The Honeymooners.
我的意思是，Jenna，我从小就玩它们。我们现在还在玩。一样。让我告诉你“疯狂填词”的历史。好的。“疯狂填词”是 1953 年由两个人发明的：伦纳德·斯特恩（Leonard Stern）和罗杰·普莱斯（Roger Price）。罗杰·普莱斯曾在鲍勃·霍普秀（Bob Hope Show）担任编剧。伦纳德·斯特恩是他的朋友，曾在《蜜月期》（The Honeymooners）担任编剧。
They were comedy writers. Yeah. One day, Roger went to visit Leonard at work, and Leonard was working on a script for the honeymooners. He was trying to figure out the right word to describe the nose of Ralph Cramden's new boss. Before he could explain the whole thing, he just said to his friend, I need an adjective, and Price jumped in and started throwing out words like clumsy, naked.
他们是喜剧编剧。是的。有一天，罗杰去伦纳德的工作单位拜访他，伦纳德正在为《蜜月期》写剧本。他正试图找出合适的词来描述拉尔夫·克拉姆登（Ralph Cramden）新老板的鼻子。在他能解释清楚之前，他只是对他的朋友说：“我需要一个形容词。”普莱斯跳了进来，开始抛出像“笨拙的”、“裸体的”这样的词。
He just started throwing out adjectives. So they thought this was so funny, right? Like, oh, a clumsy nose, a naked nose. So this gave them the idea to write a bunch of stories with missing words. They took them to a cocktail party with their friends. They had people fill in the blanks without knowing the. context and it was a huge hit. People thought this was a hoot. They tried to get these stories published, but publishers passed. Nobody wanted them. They said, we don't get it. Maybe sell it to a
他只是开始抛出形容词。所以他们认为这太搞笑了，对吧？比如，哦，一个笨拙的鼻子，一个裸体的鼻子。所以这给了他们写一堆缺少单词的故事的想法。他们带着这些故事去参加朋友的鸡尾酒会。他们让人们在不知道上下文的情况下填空，结果大受欢迎。人们认为这太有趣了。他们试图出版这些故事，但出版商拒绝了。没人想要它们。他们说：“我们不懂。也许卖给游戏公司什么的。”这听起来像个派对游戏。所以他们把这个想法搁置了五年。然后他们决定自费出版。但现在他们需要一个名字，对吧？是的。他们有所有的故事，他们要自费出版。听着。这两个家伙在纽约吃早餐，无意中听到一个经纪人在另一张桌子上和他的客户争论。经纪人试图告诉这个演员，他必须为即将到来的采访背诵特定的剧本。而演员说：“不，我想即兴发挥我的采访。我想即兴发挥它。”
game company or something. It sounds like a party game. So they sat on the idea for five years. And then they decided to self-publish. But now they needed a name for it, right? Yeah. They had all their stories, they're self-publishing. Get this. These two guys, they're out having breakfast in New and they overheard an agent arguing with his client at another table. And the agent was trying to tell this actor that he had to recite a certain script for an upcoming interview. And the actor was saying, no, I want to ad lib my interview. I want to ad libid it.
经纪人说：“即兴发挥采访会很疯狂（Mad）。”这就是“Madlib”这个名字的由来。现在他们已经卖出了超过 1.1 亿本“疯狂填词”书。这太棒了。我喜欢其中的每一刻。我也觉得很鼓舞人心的是，你可以拥有这种千载难逢的想法，并且不要放弃它，即使它花了你六年时间才实现。是的，他们发现了什么，他们知道这一点，他们让它发生了。
And the agent said that would be mad to ad lib an interview. And that's where the name Madlib came from. And now they have sold over 110 million copies of Madlib's books. That was amazing. I loved every single moment of that. I also find it really inspiring that you can have this once-in-a-lifetime idea, and don't let go of it, even if it takes you six years to see it come like to fruition. Yeah, they were onto something and they knew it and they made it happen.
我喜欢那个。很棒的深度挖掘。谢谢。好吧。好吧，现在迈克尔要从他的办公室出来，他会立即注意到帕姆和她的眼镜。他对她说：“你知道吗，为了变得更性感，你必须摘掉那些眼镜。她正朝着错误的方向发展。”是的。
I love that. Great deep dive. Thanks. All right. Well, now Michael's going to come out of his office and immediately he's going to clock Pam and her glasses. and he says to her, you know what, in order to get hotter, you've got to take off those glasses. She's just going in the wrong direction. Yes.
帕姆试图向迈克尔解释发生了什么，为什么她戴着这些眼镜。他有一句人们一直引用给我的台词。他说：“向上，向上，向上，但这只是从一个丑陋的科学家嘴里发出的噪音。”迈克尔。我喜欢它。每次史蒂夫说那句话时，我都很难坚持下去。我敢打赌。我觉得我在 T 恤上见过那个，Jenna。
And Pam tries to explain to Michael what happened, why she's wearing these glasses. And he has this line that people quote to me all the time. He's like, up, up, up, but it's noise coming out of an ugly scientist. Michael. I love it. That was really hard for me to get through every time Steve said that. I bet. I feel like I've seen that on a t-shirt, Jenna.
哦，是的。哦，你见过。想象一下，对于一个从未看过《办公室》的人来说，看到有人穿着这些 T 恤，比如：“德怀特，你这个无知的荡妇。”“这只是从一个丑陋的科学家嘴里发出的噪音。”我觉得《办公室》给人们提供了一些非常随机的服装选择。好吧，当我在现实生活中戴上眼镜，并在 Instagram 上发布了我戴着新眼镜的第一张照片时，人们开始发表所有这些评论。他们说：“你正朝着错误的方向发展。你必须摘掉眼镜才能变得更性感。”
Oh, yeah. Oh, you have. Imagine for someone who's never seen the office and then like see someone in these t-shirts like, Dwight, you ignorant slut. It's just noise coming out of an ugly scientist. I feel like the office has given some really random clothing choices for people. Well, when I got my glasses in real life and I posted my first picture on Instagram of myself in my new glasses, people started putting all of these comments. They were like, you're going in the wrong direction. You have to take off your glasses to get hotter.
然后其他人说：“这是从它嘴里发出的噪音。”我被冒犯了。我忘了《办公室》里的这个场景。我心想，为什么每个人都针对我？我觉得我的眼镜很可爱。我知道。我太有同感了。有一次，我在 Instagram 的早期发布了一张我穿着绿色毛衣的照片。
And then other people were like, it's noise coming out of it. I was so offended. I forgot about this scene in the office. And I was like, why is everybody coming down on me? I thought my glasses were cute. I know. I so relate. One time I posted a photo early in my Instagram days in a green sweater.
然后其他人就说，那里面发出了噪音。我当时太受冒犯了。我忘了《办公室》里还有这一幕。我当时心想，为什么大家都针对我？我觉得我的眼镜很可爱啊。我懂，我太有共鸣了。有一次，在我刚开始用Instagram的时候，我发了一张穿着绿色毛衣的照片。
And someone was like, looking a little horish, aren't we? And I was like, wow, how rude. And then I was like, oh, right, green is horridish. Okay, okay, got it, got it, got it. I know. Sometimes I forget. I'm actually grateful that we're doing this rewatch because I feel like I'm less likely to be offended by comments now
有人说，看起来有点像妓女，不是吗？我说，哇，真没礼貌。然后我心想，哦，对了，绿色确实有点像妓女。好吧，好吧，知道了，知道了。我知道。有时候我会忘记。其实我很庆幸我们在做这次重温，因为我觉得我现在不太容易被评论冒犯了
because they're actually quotes. Well, after all the insults, Michael tells everyone to go into the conference room for a brainstorming session. Oh, lady, there is a scene between Jim and Pam that is not in this episode, and it's not in the deleted scene, and so you have to tell me if you guys film this, it's kind of racy. You want to hear it? What? So I'm reading the shooting draft last night, and this is in there. As people head to the conference room, Jim smiles at Pam.
因为它们实际上是引用。好吧，在所有的侮辱之后，迈克尔让大家去会议室进行头脑风暴。哦，女士，吉姆和帕姆之间有一个场景，这一集里没有，删减片段里也没有，所以你得告诉我你们是否拍了这个，有点色情。你想听吗？什么？所以我昨晚在读拍摄剧本，里面有这个。当人们前往会议室时，吉姆对帕姆微笑。
Jim says, the price you pay for a night in heaven. Oh, wait. Pam glances at the camera, stilted. Yes, the movies were good, Jim. Jim says, you mean the movies that we made of us, making love? Pam, panicking, glances to camera. Shut up. We didn't film ourselves. Jim to camera. Hi, Pam's grandma, sorry you had to find out like this.
吉姆说，这是你在天堂过夜的代价。哦，等等。帕姆瞥了一眼摄像机，僵住了。是的，电影很好看，吉姆。吉姆说，你是说我们拍的关于我们做爱的电影吗？帕姆惊慌失措地瞥了一眼摄像机。闭嘴。我们没有拍自己。吉姆对摄像机说。嗨，帕姆的奶奶，很抱歉你不得不以这种方式发现。
And then Pam hits Jim and they go into the conference room. What? I don't remember if we filmed that. If it's in the shooting draft, we must have. People would have lost their minds if we'd left that in the show. I know. Like, what the heck? I read it last night and I was like, like I did a spit take.
然后帕姆打了吉姆，他们走进会议室。什么？我不记得我们是否拍过那个。如果它在拍摄剧本里，我们肯定拍过。如果我们把它留在剧集里，人们会疯掉的。我知道。就像，搞什么鬼？我昨晚读到它时，就像，我差点喷出来。
I was like, what's happening with Jim and Pam? Just hearing that makes me feel like I've just walked in on my parents. I know. Having an intimate moment. Like, I just like, no, no, no, don't want to see it. Don't want to see it. Which is probably why it was edited out. But it cracked me up reading it.
我心想，吉姆和帕姆怎么了？光是听到这个就让我觉得我好像撞见了我父母。我知道。正在进行亲密时刻。就像，我只是，不，不，不，不想看到它。不想看到它。这可能就是它被剪掉的原因。但读到它让我笑得前仰后合。
Wow. Well, there you go, guys. There you go. Now we're in the conference room. the actual scene they leave in between the two of you guys is Jim proposing to Pam, which is also in the script. So I guess if they had to choose one, that one is a little bit more in character for you guys. Well, proposing that I go get him some more coffee. Right, right, right. But you're doing the, you know, he's now doing this bit with you, right? Yeah. Well, Michael has written the
哇。好吧，就是这样，伙计们。就是这样。现在我们在会议室了。你们俩之间留下的实际场景是吉姆向帕姆求婚，这也在剧本里。所以我想如果他们必须选一个，那一个对你们来说更符合角色。好吧，提议我去给他拿更多咖啡。对，对，对。但你在做那个，你知道，他现在在和你演这个戏，对吧？是的。好吧，迈克尔写了
words energize in block letters on a piece of paper up front. And he wants to know how can we energize the office. A few people are throwing out ideas. Andy suggests that we have a new outgoing message, something with Zing and Pep. Jim suggests we have an even better message with more Zing and more PEP. Michael wants to get Stanley's opinion. Stanley's not having it. He's like, not me. He's not interesting. He's not even answering him. I know. And Michael keeps pushing and pushing and pushing. And that is when he says the line, Did I stutter? And everyone is stunned.
“激励”这个词，用大写字母写在前面的一张纸上。他想知道我们如何激励办公室。几个人提出了一些想法。安迪建议我们有一个新的外发信息，带点活力和干劲。吉姆建议我们有一个更好的信息，有更多的活力和更多的干劲。迈克尔想听听斯坦利的意见。斯坦利不买账。他说，别找我。他甚至不感兴趣。他甚至没回答他。我知道。迈克尔一直推啊推啊推。就在那时，他说出了那句台词，“我结巴了吗？”每个人都惊呆了。
We're like, whoa, this just took a turn. Michael excuses himself for a glass of water. Oof. Oof. Now, Jenna, per Justin Spitzer, this is the only episode title that was an actual line in the script. Yes, Justin said
我们心想，哇，这下转折了。迈克尔借口去喝杯水。哎呀。哎呀。现在，珍娜，根据贾斯汀·斯皮策的说法，这是唯一一个剧本里有实际台词的剧集标题。是的，贾斯汀说
he had originally thought they should call it insuffer, insubordination. Oh. But they settled on Did I Stutter? Well, I like Did I Stutter better. Me too. Next up, we're in Michael's office, and Toby is sitting with him, and he's trying to tell Michael that he needs to talk with Stanley about his insubordination. And once again, Toby is in Michael's corner. And Michael just refuses to see Toby as someone who could be there for him. Yeah. He tries to tell Toby that he misinterpreted what he saw, that they were actually a couple of pals. They're kind of joshing around.
他最初认为他们应该叫它“不服从”。哦。但他们决定叫“我结巴了吗？”好吧，我更喜欢“我结巴了吗？”我也是。接下来，我们在迈克尔的办公室，托比和他坐在一起，他试图告诉迈克尔他需要和斯坦利谈谈他的不服从。再一次，托比站在迈克尔这边。而迈克尔只是拒绝把托比看作一个可以支持他的人。是的。他试图告诉托比他误解了他所看到的，他们实际上是一对好朋友。他们只是在开玩笑。
Toby wouldn't know because Toby doesn't have friends, Michael says. Yeah. If you had a friend, you would say something like this. Hey, you're poor. Well, hey, your mom is dead. That's what friends do. Yeah. So there you go, Toby.
托比不知道，因为托比没有朋友，迈克尔说。是的。如果你有一个朋友，你会说这样的话。嘿，你很穷。好吧，嘿，你妈妈死了。朋友就是这么做的。是的。所以就是这样，托比。
Get some friends. But it's clear at the end of this meeting that Michael is going to be expected to do something about what happened. It's also clear that Michael's really anxious about it. He says he has a stomach ache. Mm-hmm. And Jenna, there's a deleted scene. It's so great. First of all, it shows the geography of Dundra Mifflin in a whole new way that we've never seen before. So in this deleted scene, there's a talking head and it's over the action.
交些朋友吧。但这次会议结束时很清楚，迈克尔将被要求对发生的事情做点什么。也很清楚迈克尔对此非常焦虑。他说他胃疼。嗯哼。而且珍娜，有一个删减片段。太棒了。首先，它以一种我们从未见过的新方式展示了邓德·米夫林的地理位置。所以在这个删减片段中，有一个谈话头，它在动作之上。
You know what I mean? And Michael is talking about how him and Stanley are friends. In fact, Stanley is one of his oldest friends. But while he's saying all this, he's walking out of his office and he clearly has to go pee and he sees Stanley and he pivots hard. right. He goes out the front door of Dundermifflin, pass the elevators to the stairwell door next to Vance refrigeration. He goes down the stairs, out the front door of Dundermifflin, through the parking lot to a back door that's another stairwell up those stairs and he comes out by the break room, by the vending machines. And then he walks through the annex into the kitchen, into the men's room.
你知道我的意思吗？迈克尔在谈论他和斯坦利是朋友。事实上，斯坦利是他最老的朋友之一。但当他说这一切时，他正走出办公室，他显然必须去小便，他看到了斯坦利，他猛地转过身。对。他从邓德·米夫林的前门出去，经过电梯到万斯制冷旁边的楼梯间门。他走下楼梯，从邓德·米夫林的前门出去，穿过停车场到一个后门，那是另一个楼梯间，上那些楼梯，他从休息室旁边，自动售货机旁边出来。然后他穿过附楼进入厨房，进入男洗手间。
That's what he did because he had to go pee and he did not. not want to walk past Stanley's desk. Wow. And we've never seen anyone in the run of the show come up the back stairwell into the area where the break room is. That's right. I loved it just visually. And that shows you the extremes he was going to to avoid Stanley. Well, now we're going to get into the B storyline of this episode, which is that Andy is selling his car, his exterra, and Dwight is going to buy it. His extero, when he was driving a Prius, so I don't know what's happening here. I know.
他就是这么做的，因为他必须去小便，而且他不想走过斯坦利的办公桌。哇。在剧集中，我们从未见过任何人从后楼梯上来进入休息室所在的区域。没错。我从视觉上就很喜欢它。这表明他为了避开斯坦利而采取的极端措施。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集的B故事线，那就是安迪在卖他的车，他的Xterra，而德怀特要买它。他的Xterra，当他开着普锐斯时，所以我不知道这里发生了什么。我知道。
What's that about? You know what? In my mind, it was like his old car from college. Hmm. Maybe so. From his Cornell days? Well, we had a fan question from Barbara G and Rebecca H. At 6 minutes, 45 seconds, Dwight points out that there's a scratch on Andy's Xtera.
那是怎么回事？你知道吗？在我看来，那就像他大学时的旧车。嗯。也许吧。从他康奈尔大学的日子开始？好吧，我们有一个来自芭芭拉·G和丽贝卡·H的粉丝问题。在6分45秒，德怀特指出安迪的Xterra上有划痕。
In a deleted scene from safety training, Angela, you might remember, Angela Keyes Andy's car. Did Angela also key his Xterra? I don't think so. I think she just keyed the Prius. But in the script, you guys, Angela is watching all of this interaction between Dwight and Andy. She is perhaps titillated by it, fascinated, curious. But there are several scenes where she's peering through the window, the camera busts her at one point and she gets agitated. So she is sort of watching all of this all day long.
在《安全培训》的一个删减片段中，安吉拉，你可能记得，安吉拉划了安迪的车。安吉拉也划了他的Xterra吗？我不这么认为。我想她只是划了普锐斯。但在剧本里，你们，安吉拉正在观察德怀特和安迪之间的所有互动。她可能对此感到兴奋、着迷、好奇。但有几个场景她透过窗户窥视，摄像机在某个时刻抓住了她，她变得焦躁不安。所以她整天都在观察这一切。
Well, Dwight ends up bullying Andy into selling him the car at a very low rate, way under asking. He does that thing where he's like, do it, sell it, give it to me, say yes now, say yes. Three, two, one, five, four, three, say yes. And it works. He says, okay. Now, here's an interesting tidbit. This car, this Xtera, actually belonged to our hairdresser Kim Ferry. And she was actually selling it.
好吧，德怀特最终欺负安迪以极低的价格把车卖给他，远低于要价。他做了那种事，就像，做吧，卖掉它，给我，现在说好，说好。三，二，一，五，四，三，说好。它奏效了。他说，好吧。现在，这是一个有趣的片段。这辆车，这辆Xterra，实际上属于我们的理发师金·费里。她实际上在卖它。
She was. It was so crazy. She let us borrow her car for this episode. And then she sold it, just like these guys. Well, I guess Michael is going to finally baby step up to Stanley's desk. And he's basically going to forgive Stanley before Stanley has even apologized. But the way he approaches Stanley really reminds me of like when my kids want something, but they don't want to ask me.
她是。太疯狂了。她让我们借用她的车拍这一集。然后她把它卖了，就像这些家伙一样。好吧，我想迈克尔终于要迈出小步走到斯坦利的办公桌前了。他基本上要在斯坦利道歉之前原谅斯坦利。但他接近斯坦利的方式真的让我想起我的孩子们想要什么，但他们不想问我的时候。
and they just come and stand by you and kind of hover. Yeah. He's just standing next to Stanley's desk. And Stanley's like, yeah, what do you want? Yeah. And he's like, you know, nothing. I think I just want to say like we're cool, right? Like, I forgive you.
他们只是过来站在你身边，有点徘徊。是的。他只是站在斯坦利的办公桌旁边。斯坦利说，是的，你想要什么？是的。他说，你知道，没什么。我想我只是想说我们很酷，对吧？就像，我原谅你。
And we've forgotten about what happened. Right? Yeah. Now, Stanley could just say yes. I know. But he does not. I think Stanley has had years of putting. up with Michael and he's just had it. Yeah. Since that didn't work, Michael is going to sit with Dwight
我们已经忘记了发生的事情。对吧？是的。现在，斯坦利可以只说好。我知道。但他没有。我想斯坦利已经忍受了迈克尔多年，他受够了。是的。既然那没用，迈克尔要和德怀特坐在一起
and try to figure out, is there a way that someone else might be able to discipline Stanley? Does Stanley report to anyone else besides Michael? And this is when Dwight gets out his very extensive, very hilarious employee org chart. It's so elaborate. It was really well made. He has a a, like, tripod he sets it on. There's, like, an overlay. I mean, Jenna, this thing was not cheap. Well, Brent told us that the entire writing staff put a huge amount of time and effort into that org chart and that they had the idea that after this episode, NBC could sell
并试图弄清楚，有没有可能其他人可以管教斯坦利？斯坦利除了迈克尔之外还向其他人汇报吗？就在这时，德怀特拿出了他非常详尽、非常搞笑的员工组织结构图。太复杂了。做得非常好。他有一个，像三脚架一样把它放在上面。有一个，像覆盖层。我是说，珍娜，这东西不便宜。好吧，布伦特告诉我们，整个编剧团队在那个组织结构图上投入了大量的时间和精力，他们有一个想法，在这一集之后，NBC可以卖
the org chart as posters. So they filled it with all these little jokes that you can't even really spot in the episode itself. And unfortunately, though, the poster did not become the runaway bestseller. They had hoped it would be. However, Kent Sabornak sent me a picture of it and we will put it in the pod so you can really unpack it if you'd like. Yeah, I looked at that last night and the detail of the menstruation cycles of the women, you know, Dwight has shared that he clocks all of that. Well, he wasn't kidding. Angela, we got a fan question about this scene at nine minutes, 34 seconds. Did Rain, improvised touching Michael's face with his pointer?
组织结构图作为海报。所以他们填满了所有这些你在剧集本身中甚至无法真正发现的小笑话。但不幸的是，海报并没有成为他们希望的那样畅销。然而，肯特·萨博纳克给我发了一张照片，我们会把它放在播客里，如果你愿意，你可以真正解开它。是的，我昨晚看了那个，女性月经周期的细节，你知道，德怀特分享过他记录了所有这些。好吧，他没开玩笑。安吉拉，我们有一个关于这个场景的粉丝问题，在9分34秒。雷恩是用他的指针触碰迈克尔的脸吗？
Yes. Yes, he did. And they could not get through it. They were cracking up something so sort of delicate and intimate about Dwight touching Michael's face with that metal pointer. And those two fellas were just disintegrating into laughter. It's in the bloopers. It's so fun to watch.
是的。是的，他做了。他们无法通过它。他们笑得前仰后合，德怀特用那个金属指针触碰迈克尔的脸，有一种微妙而亲密的感觉。那两个家伙只是笑得崩溃了。它在花絮里。看它太有趣了。
Justin said before they started the scene, they had to decide whether or not Rain would have that metal pointer or a laser pointer. And he's so glad. I'm so glad they gave him the metal pointer. Yeah. Brent said that after Rain improvised it once, they loved it and they had him do it again. And it took over seven takes before they got even three seconds of usable footage.
贾斯汀说在他们开始拍摄这个场景之前，他们必须决定雷恩是否会拿那个金属指针或激光指针。他很高兴。我很高兴他们给了他金属指针。是的。布伦特说在雷恩即兴发挥一次后，他们很喜欢它，并让他再做一次。花了七次以上才得到三秒钟可用的镜头。
And that's what you see in the episode was like take number eight. Well, back at reception, Kevin is complimenting Pam's glasses. I mean, they're kind of a turn on for him. Jenna, there's a lot more. in the script. In fact, Kevin says you're basically in his league now. So I think there were a few alts for this scene. I remember shooting it. We were laughing so hard. There's also that famous line where he says, can you say these are due back Thursday? And Pam's like, no. No. At nine minutes 58 seconds, at the very top of this interaction between Pam and Kevin, I want you to
这就是你在剧集中看到的，就像第八次拍摄。好吧，回到接待处，凯文在称赞帕姆的眼镜。我是说，它们对他来说有点吸引力。珍娜，剧本里还有更多。事实上，凯文说你现在基本上在他的联盟里了。所以我认为这个场景有几个替代方案。我记得拍摄它。我们笑得太厉害了。还有那句著名的台词，他说，你能说这些周四要还吗？帕姆说，不。不。在9分58秒，在帕姆和凯文互动的最开始，我想让你
know that John is actively playing free cell on his computer. Oh, I saw. It's not just on his computer. You can see him moving the car. Oh, no. He's full on playing. But this interaction between Kevin and Pam is going to cause Pam to take her glasses off now for the rest of the day. She's done. She's sick of the comments.
知道约翰正在他的电脑上积极地玩纸牌游戏。哦，我看到了。不仅仅是在他的电脑上。你可以看到他在移动牌。哦，不。他完全在玩。但凯文和帕姆之间的这种互动将导致帕姆在这一天的剩余时间里摘下眼镜。她受够了。她厌倦了这些评论。
She's just going to not see. But how bad is this woman's vision? Because she takes her glasses off and then Jenna, the phone rings and she has a hard time finding the handle of the phone. There is a talking head that did not make it in the end. episode. Oh, yeah. Where Pam says that her vision is 20 slash 400. I'll have you know, Angela, legal blindness is anything that's 20 slash 200 or worse. So Pam would be considered legally blind without her glasses or contacts. And basically what it means is that Pam can see things 20 feet away, but normal people could see that same thing 400 feet away. So it doesn't really track
她只是不打算看。但这女人的视力有多差？因为她摘下眼镜，然后珍娜，电话响了，她很难找到电话的手柄。有一个谈话头最终没有进入剧集。哦，是的。帕姆说她的视力是20/400。我要告诉你，安吉拉，法定盲人是任何20/200或更差的视力。所以帕姆在没有眼镜或隐形眼镜的情况下会被认为是法定盲人。基本上这意味着帕姆可以看到20英尺远的东西，但正常人可以看到同样的东西在400英尺远。所以这真的不符合
that Pam can't see the phone. Okay. What it should mean is that she can't see Stanley anymore. Okay. Yeah. So maybe we didn't research her eyesight properly. But in general, though, all of her vision would be fairly blurry. I do remember researching that.
帕姆看不见电话。好吧。它应该意味着她再也看不见斯坦利了。好吧。是的。所以也许我们没有正确研究她的视力。但总的来说，她所有的视力都会相当模糊。我确实记得研究过那个。
Well, I thought you played it so well, Jenna, because that's not an easy thing to play. And the physicality of your comedy in this episode is fantastic. Well, thank you very much. Yes. Well, guys, Michael's going to go down to the warehouse and try to get maybe some advice on how to deal with Stanley. But before we go there, let's take a break. And then we'll come back to learn a little bit about fluffy fingers.
好吧，我觉得你演得太好了，珍娜，因为那不是一件容易演的事情。你在这一集里的喜剧肢体语言太棒了。好吧，非常感谢。是的。好吧，伙计们，迈克尔要下到仓库，试着得到一些关于如何处理斯坦利的建议。但在我们去那里之前，让我们休息一下。然后我们会回来了解一点关于“蓬松手指”的事情。
Okay, guys, we're back. And as promised, we're going to break down this scene between Michael and Daryl. It's amazing. Everything about it is amazing. Even just from a technical standpoint, this was such a time. tiny, tiny room, and Randall had to shoot through the door in a window and capture this moment. It's so beautifully done. Michael's going to ask Daryl, hey man, have you ever been in a gang?
好吧，伙计们，我们回来了。正如承诺的那样，我们要剖析迈克尔和达里尔之间的这个场景。太棒了。关于它的一切都很棒。即使从技术角度来看，这也是一个时代。非常非常小的房间，兰德尔必须通过门和窗户拍摄并捕捉这一刻。做得太美了。迈克尔要问达里尔，嘿伙计，你有没有参加过帮派？
And Daryl needs to know what Michael needs to say. Yeah. So he says he has been in not just one gang, but several. Yeah. He has been in the Crips and the Bloods and the Warriors and. the newsies. And the newsies on Broadway. And Michael is just like, oh my God. Yeah. Oh my God. And Michael can't believe that Daryl is now about to share with him his like deep gang knowledge. Yeah. What do you do if you're disrespected in the gang? Daryl's going to tell him they do something called Fluffy
达里尔需要知道迈克尔需要说什么。是的。所以他说他参加过，不仅是一个帮派，而是几个。是的。他参加过Crips和Bloods和Warriors和。报童。还有百老汇的报童。迈克尔就像，哦，天哪。是的。哦，天哪。迈克尔不敢相信达里尔现在要和他分享他那深厚的帮派知识。是的。如果你在帮派里被不尊重，你该怎么办？达里尔要告诉他他们做一种叫“蓬松”的事情
Fingers. And that is where you surprise the person by tickle. them. And you keep tickling them until they start to tickle you. And then you're just tickling each other. Yeah. And then you're over it. It's really effective, he says. And Michael's like, wow, I didn't think that's how it went in the gangs. But okay. Okay. Michael's like, all right. I guess I should try this. It's so great. And both Steve and Craig play it perfectly. Oh, yeah. Well, you know, Jenna, there was a deleted scene where Michael tries to get up the courage to tickle Stanley to do the fluffy fingers. It's insane.
手指。那就是你通过挠痒痒来给那个人惊喜。你一直挠他们，直到他们开始挠你。然后你们只是在互相挠痒痒。是的。然后你就没事了。他说，这非常有效。迈克尔说，哇，我没想到帮派里是这样的。但好吧。好吧。迈克尔说，好吧。我想我应该试试这个。太棒了。史蒂夫和克雷格都演得非常完美。哦，是的。好吧，你知道，珍娜，有一个删减片段，迈克尔试图鼓起勇气去挠斯坦利，做蓬松手指。太疯狂了。
Stanley is at the supply cabinet. He's kind of reaching up to grab something and Michael sneaks up behind him and he holds his hands up like he's going to tickle him. But then he just can't quite figure out how to do it and Stanley doesn't even notice and Michael backs away. And then Michael has a deleted talking head where he says it's not Darrell's fault. It was a great idea. I just couldn't quite figure out how to do it. I don't know. I've tried everything.
斯坦利在供应柜旁。他有点伸手去拿东西，迈克尔悄悄走到他身后，他举起手，好像要挠他。但他就是无法弄清楚怎么做，斯坦利甚至没注意到，迈克尔退缩了。然后迈克尔有一个删减的谈话头，他说这不是达里尔的错。这是一个好主意。我只是无法弄清楚怎么做。我不知道。我试过一切。
I'm running out of options. Yeah. And when you run out of options, you decide to fake fire someone. That's what Michael does. Oh, Michael. So now Ryan has arrived. He pulls up in his convertible. His shirt is open.
我没招了。是的。当你没招时，你决定假装解雇某人。这就是迈克尔做的。哦，迈克尔。所以现在瑞安到了。他开着敞篷车停下。他的衬衫敞开着。
He winks at himself in the rearview mirror. Oh yeah, he's feeling real good. And there was a deleted scene, Jenna, that was so good. He comes in the office. He's got bagels. But Pam doesn't have her glasses on. He tosses a bagel at her. She can't see it.
他在后视镜里对自己眨眼。哦，是的，他感觉非常好。有一个删减片段，珍娜，太好了。他走进办公室。他带着百吉饼。但帕姆没戴眼镜。他扔了一个百吉饼给她。她看不见。
It hits her in the face. And then he goes on, Jenna, to show Pam how to eat a bagel. He just, with his own hands, starts digging out all the good part of the bagel, all the middle part. And he says, yeah, you just eat that outer part, you know, so you don't gain weight. and he kind of points to Pam's belly. Yeah. And I felt like that whole scene showed his state of mind, how manic he is, throwing the bagels, digging him apart.
它打在她的脸上。然后他继续，珍娜，向帕姆展示如何吃百吉饼。他只是，用他自己的手，开始挖出百吉饼所有好的部分，所有中间的部分。他说，是的，你只是吃外面的部分，你知道，这样你就不会增加体重。他有点指着帕姆的肚子。是的。我觉得整个场景展示了他的心态，他有多狂躁，扔百吉饼，把它们挖开。
Like, oh, my gosh. I remember shooting that. I was sad it didn't make it in because that was really fun. You were so good in it. I mean, he tosses a bagel at you. And Jenna, I really believed you didn't see it. That's how good you are in the scene. Anyway, so Ryan is here.
就像，哦，天哪。我记得拍摄那个。我很遗憾它没有进入，因为那真的很有趣。你在里面演得太好了。我是说，他扔了一个百吉饼给你。而且珍娜，我真的相信你没看见。这就是你在场景里演得有多好。总之，瑞安在这里。
He's actually got some big business. He goes in the conference room. And he calls Jim in. Toby's there. And he's going to give him a formal warning about his job performance. But the way he calls him in is so amazing. He's like, hey, Jim, Jim, I got to ask you a question as a true Eagles fan. Oh, so slimy. I thought BJ was so good in this scene. He was like every douchebag I've ever had a meeting with. I actually recorded it off my computer and I texted it to him. And I said, B.J. We're watching did I stutter and you are so brilliant and amazing in the scene. I just needed you to watch it so you can see how good you are. And he wrote me back and he was like, Jenna, oh my God,
他确实有一些大生意。他走进会议室。他叫吉姆进来。托比在那里。他要给他一个关于他工作表现的正式警告。但他叫他进来的方式太神奇了。他说，嘿，吉姆，吉姆，我作为一个真正的老鹰队球迷必须问你一个问题。哦，太卑鄙了。我觉得BJ在这个场景里演得太好了。他就像我曾经开过会的每一个混蛋。我实际上从我的电脑上录下来，我发短信给他。我说，BJ。我们正在看“我结巴了吗”，你在这个场景里太出色、太棒了。我只是需要你看一下，这样你就能看到你有多好。他回信给我，他说，珍娜，哦，天哪，
I forgot about that scene. Thank you for sending this to me. That was so fun to watch. But that happens when we are rewatching this show. Sometimes I will see one of our friends perform just like madness level amazing. And I just send it to him. I'm like, you need to be reminded of what amazing comedic actor you are. You're welcome. Oh, for sure. I had a whole text thread with Phyllis because I was like, Phyllis, you are so amazing. Back in Yankee Swap. She's so good. I know. Yes, BJ is so good in these moments. And Jim is like, is this because I talked to David Wallace? And Ryan's like, no, no, no. I appreciate, you know, constructive criticism. I thrive on it. Yeah. So do she. And he says, you can get more details from Toby.
我忘了那个场景。谢谢你发给我。看那个太有趣了。但当我们重温这部剧时，这种情况就会发生。有时我会看到我们的一个朋友表演得简直是疯狂级别的棒。我只是发给他。我说，你需要被提醒你是一个多么出色的喜剧演员。不客气。哦，当然。我和菲利斯有一个完整的短信串，因为我说，菲利斯，你太棒了。回到“洋基交换”。她太好了。我知道。是的，BJ在这些时刻太棒了。吉姆说，这是因为我和大卫·华莱士谈过吗？瑞安说，不，不，不。我欣赏，你知道，建设性的批评。我靠它茁壮成长。是的。她也一样。他说，你可以从托比那里得到更多细节。
This leads to a Toby talking head. And dare I say that Toby seems smug? Oh, for sure. Yeah. Toby says, I'd say all the goofing around at Pam's desk and hanging out with Pam has finally caught up with him. Fans were furious, Jenna. When this episode came out, they hated Toby so much. I mean, in the episode before, he put his hand on Pam's knee.
这导致了一个托比的谈话头。我敢说托比看起来很自鸣得意吗？哦，当然。是的。托比说，我会说在帕姆办公桌旁所有的胡闹和与帕姆闲逛终于让他付出了代价。粉丝们很愤怒，珍娜。当这一集出来时，他们非常讨厌托比。我是说，在上一集里，他把手放在帕姆的膝盖上。
Mm-hmm. And now it seems like he's going behind Jim's back to try to get him fired. Oh, yeah. And Jenna, if you thought you hated Toby with that talking head, had you seen the deleted scene between Jim and Toby and then Ryan? You would have been like, oh my God, people would have, Toby would not have been able to come back from it. Sam, can you play that deleted scene? A formal warning, seriously. Well, as you know, the way has filed a lot of complaints against you over the years.
嗯哼。现在看起来他要背着吉姆试图让他被解雇。哦，是的。而且珍娜，如果你以为你讨厌托比的那个谈话头，你有没有看过吉姆和托比然后是瑞安之间的删减片段？你会说，哦，天哪，人们会，托比将无法从中恢复过来。萨姆，你能播放那个删减片段吗？正式警告，认真的。好吧，如你所知，方式多年来对你提出了很多投诉。
I know and cared. But now it's being looked at as more of a productivity issue. Productivity. My numbers are good. I know. but Ryan thinks that they're not good enough. Wallace likes Jim, so going after him, that's a risky move for me. But in business, you've got to take risks.
我知道并且关心。但现在它被视为更多的是一个生产力问题。生产力。我的数字很好。我知道。但瑞安认为它们不够好。华莱士喜欢吉姆，所以去对付他，对我来说是一个冒险的举动。但在商业中，你必须冒险。
Sometimes you've got to get out on the open highway with a top down. Oh my God! And Ryan is trying to put the top down to his car and it won't go down. Wow. But yeah, can you imagine if those scenes have been left in? Oh. Well, Angela, speaking of treachery, Dwight has washed the X-Dera and he's now reselling it for over $9,000. He's selling it for a profit. Oh, and Andy is like, what the hell, man? Angel is impressed. Angela's like, oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. You got him. You're smarter.
有时你必须在敞篷车上开上开阔的高速公路。哦，天哪！瑞安正试图把他的车顶放下来，但它放不下来。哇。但是的，你能想象如果那些场景被留下来吗？哦。好吧，安吉拉，说到背叛，德怀特洗了Xterra，他现在以超过9000美元的价格转售它。他正在盈利出售它。哦，安迪说，搞什么鬼，伙计？安吉拉印象深刻。安吉拉说，哦，是的。嗯哼。你抓住了他。你更聪明。
She loves two men dueling over her. She really does. I know. You guys, remember, Michael has run out of options. Fluffy fingers isn't going to work for him. So he's going to have to do the thing he didn't want to do. He's going to have to fake fire Stanley to teach him a lesson. And he comes out of his office and he announces it to everyone. He says, guys, guys, guys, listen, I'm going to fake fire Stanley, but I just want you to react as if I'm really firing Stanley.
她喜欢两个男人为她决斗。她真的喜欢。我知道。你们，记住，迈克尔没招了。蓬松手指对他不起作用。所以他将不得不做他不想做的事情。他将不得不假装解雇斯坦利来给他一个教训。他从办公室出来，向大家宣布。他说，伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，听着，我要假装解雇斯坦利，但我只是想让你们表现得好像我真的在解雇斯坦利。
And everybody's like, if you hadn't told us what you were doing, we would have reacted correctly. And he's like, oh my gosh, why aren't you understanding this? The person that says it. The person that's the voice of reason is Kevin. I know. You know you're in trouble when Kevin is the voice of reason. Stanley walks into the bullpen and Michael fake fires him and it does not go well. Stanley unleashes on him.
每个人都说，如果你没告诉我们你在做什么，我们会做出正确的反应。他说，哦，天哪，你们为什么不理解这个？说它的人。作为理智声音的人是凯文。我知道。当凯文是理智的声音时，你就知道你有麻烦了。斯坦利走进牛棚，迈克尔假装解雇他，结果并不好。斯坦利对他发火了。
Just a tirade of insults. I remember when we filmed this, Jenna, and you could have heard a pin drop. Yes. It was such a beautiful. beautifully dramatic moment. Leslie crushed it. Yeah, you guys, we reached out to Leslie because we really, really wanted him to come on the pod today because this is just a tour de force storyline and performance by him in this episode. And he is filming this week. He is filming something and he couldn't come on, but he did want us to share with you that this monologue was completely scripted. This was not
只是一连串的侮辱。我记得当我们拍摄这个时，珍娜，你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。是的。这是一个如此美丽的。美丽的戏剧性时刻。莱斯利压倒了它。是的，你们，我们联系了莱斯利，因为我们真的，真的希望他今天能来播客，因为这对他来说是一个杰作故事线和表演。他这周在拍摄。他在拍摄一些东西，他不能来，但他确实希望我们与你们分享，这段独白是完全写好的。这不是
improvised, you know, and I remember Angela that he worked on this and he delivered it like it was just an amazing performance and he nailed it every take. Every take. He was 100% off book. He showed up ready to throw it down and we were just all so happy for him. This moment was amazing and I remember us all applauding at the end of the scene. Yeah. Well, Michael throws everybody out. He yells and says, everybody get out. Everybody. Except Stanley, everybody out. And everyone gets the hell out. And Jenna, in the script, which isn't in the deleted scenes, but in the script, Michael turns to the cameras and says, you two, cameras out of here. Everybody. Wow. And that's why at 18 minutes, 17 seconds, you see the cameras sneak back in. It's because in the script, Michael told them to get out.
即兴发挥，你知道，我记得安吉拉，他研究了这个，他交付它就像一个惊人的表演，他每次都做到了。每次。他100%脱稿。他准备好扔掉它，我们都为他感到高兴。这一刻太棒了，我记得我们在场景结束时鼓掌。是的。好吧，迈克尔把每个人都赶走了。他大喊并说，每个人都出去。每个人。除了斯坦利，每个人都出去。每个人都滚蛋了。而且珍娜，在剧本里，不在删减片段里，但在剧本里，迈克尔转向摄像机说，你们两个，摄像机出去。每个人。哇。这就是为什么在18分17秒，你看到摄像机溜回来。因为在剧本里，迈克尔告诉他们出去。
I loved that move. I loved it because when Michael is alone with Stanley or thinks he's alone with Stanley, he gets really vulnerable. There's tears in his eyes. And he says, why do you pick on me? Like, why do you pick on me like this? And it's really vulnerable. And Stanley, very matter of fact, he says, I don't respect you. And then I felt like Michael had such an honest moment that could not have happened if the cameras were there. And then I felt like Michael had such an honest moment that could not have happened if the cameras were there. And, where he says, fine, I accept that. You don't respect me? I accept it. But you can't talk to me like that. Here, I am your boss, and it just cannot be done. And I agree with you, Angela. Anytime Michael knows the cameras are there, he can't help but perform in some way for them. And so I feel like we're seeing a side of Michael Scott that can only be seen when he doesn't know the cameras are there. Yeah. And that was such a fun part of our show, playing with who are our characters when we know the cameras are there and when we don't. And I loved that we got to reveal these little different parts of ourselves in these different ways. Oh, me too. It made the show so rich, right? It's cool. And you know what? They have this moment of resolution. They're like, fine. We now know our rules of engagement, right? Yeah, they shake hands. Done. This leads to Michael having a talking head. He's really really. stuck on the idea of respect, getting no respect. And this just sends his brain into Rodney Dangerfield land. So he's going to do some real kind of like off-the-cuff Rodney Dangerfield impressions,
我喜欢那个动作。我喜欢它，因为当迈克尔和斯坦利单独在一起或认为他与斯坦利单独在一起时，他变得非常脆弱。他眼里有泪水。他说，你为什么挑剔我？就像，你为什么这样挑剔我？这真的很脆弱。斯坦利，非常实事求是，他说，我不尊重你。然后我觉得迈克尔有一个如此诚实的时刻，如果摄像机在那里是不可能发生的。然后我觉得迈克尔有一个如此诚实的时刻，如果摄像机在那里是不可能发生的。而且，他说，好吧，我接受。你不尊重我？我接受它。但你不能那样跟我说话。在这里，我是你的老板，这根本做不到。我同意你的看法，安吉拉。任何时候迈克尔知道摄像机在那里，他都忍不住以某种方式为它们表演。所以我感觉我们正在看到迈克尔·斯科特的一面，只有在他不知道摄像机在那里时才能看到。是的。这是我们节目中如此有趣的一部分，玩弄当摄像机在那里和不在那里时我们的角色是谁。我喜欢我们能够以这些不同的方式揭示我们这些小小的不同部分。哦，我也是。它让节目变得如此丰富，对吧？很酷。你知道吗？他们有这个解决的时刻。他们说，好吧。我们现在知道我们的交战规则了，对吧？是的，他们握手。完成了。这导致迈克尔有一个谈话头。他真的真的。卡在尊重的想法上，得不到尊重。这只是把他的大脑送进了罗德尼·丹格菲尔德的土地。所以他要做一些真正像即兴的罗德尼·丹格菲尔德模仿，
which morphs into a Jeff Foxworthy impression and then Borat and then Jerry Seinfeld and then back to Rodney Dangerfield again. It's a pretty epic talking head. It is. Well, you know, Jenna, that talking head, that whole Rodney Dangerfield comic riff, is not in the shooting draft. It's a whole other talking head. Huh. So I have to imagine they handed Steve a whole bunch of alts. They would do that to us, right? And this is the one that they picked because that is not the one in the script.
这演变成了杰夫·福克斯沃西的模仿，然后是波拉特，然后是杰瑞·宋飞，然后又回到了罗德尼·丹格菲尔德。这是一个相当史诗般的谈话头。是的。好吧，你知道，珍娜，那个谈话头，整个罗德尼·丹格菲尔德喜剧即兴，不在拍摄剧本里。那是另一个谈话头。嗯。所以我必须想象他们给了史蒂夫一大堆替代方案。他们会那样对我们，对吧？这就是他们选择的那个，因为那不是剧本里的那个。
Interesting. Well, I liked this one. I did too. And I have to think Steve improvised a little. I think it was on the page, but I can sort of see Steve doing his thing. I'm sure. While that talking head was happening, everyone else is in the parking lot, you know? They're heading home.
有趣。好吧，我喜欢这个。我也喜欢。我不得不认为史蒂夫即兴发挥了一点。我想它在页面上，但我可以某种程度上看到史蒂夫做他的事情。我肯定。当那个谈话头发生时，其他人都在停车场，你知道吗？他们正回家。
There is a wrap-up scene of the Dwight, Andy, Angela love triangle. It's in the shooting draft, and it didn't make it to the deleted scenes. But Andy and Angela walked to the car. They passed by Dwight, who is scraping off a Cornell sticker from the back window of the X-Dera. And Andy says, goodbye, old friend. May all your roads be downhill and the wind be on your back windshield. And Angela's like, Andy. And Andy says, I can't believe Dwight would do me like that.
有一个德怀特、安迪、安吉拉三角恋的总结场景。它在拍摄剧本里，它没有进入删减片段。但安迪和安吉拉走到车前。他们经过德怀特，他正在从Xterra的后窗刮掉康奈尔的贴纸。安迪说，再见，老朋友。愿你所有的道路都是下坡，风在你的后挡风玻璃上。安吉拉说，安迪。安迪说，我不敢相信德怀特会那样对我。
He took advantage of my kindness. And Angela says, he didn't take advantage of you. He bested you. You were bested. And then he tries to put his arm around her and she shoves it away. And she looks at Dwight like he's super hot. Wow. Yeah.
他利用了我的善良。安吉拉说，他没有利用你。他胜过了你。你被胜过了。然后他试图把手臂搂住她，她把它推开了。她看着德怀特，好像他超级性感。哇。是的。
Well, Angela, we should just call these deletious. scenes feisty in the parking lot because I know that over by Pam and Jim's car, there is a scene that we shot that I believe is in the deleted scenes where Jim tells Pam the truth about Ryan and what Ryan said to him that he's gunning for him to maybe get fired or put him on notice. And Pam is not having it. Oh, I titled it Pam's Pissed. Yeah. And Sam, you got to play that clip.
好吧，安吉拉，我们应该把这些删减片段称为停车场里的活泼，因为我知道在帕姆和吉姆的车旁，有一个我们拍摄的场景，我相信在删减片段里，吉姆告诉帕姆关于瑞安的真相，以及瑞安对他说的，他正在瞄准他，也许让他被解雇或让他收到通知。帕姆不买账。哦，我把它命名为“帕姆生气了”。是的。萨姆，你得播放那个片段。
Hey, what really happened today? What do you mean? I mean, I don't need my glasses to know when something's dressing you out. What happened today? Ryan is trying to get rid of me. He came in today to give me an official warning about my job performance. What? God, he's such a creep.
嘿，今天到底发生了什么？你是什么意思？我是说，我不需要眼镜就知道什么时候有什么事让你心烦意乱。今天发生了什么？瑞安正试图摆脱我。他今天进来给我一个关于我工作表现的正式警告。什么？天哪，他真是个混蛋。
That really pisses me off. I'm going to bash his face in. I'm going to bash his face in with a stale bagel. Then I'm going to throw a rock at his car. Come on, we're going to New York right now. I'm driving. If I hit him without my glasses, I don't think it's a crime. Great.
这真的让我很生气。我要把他的脸砸烂。我要用一个陈旧的百吉饼把他的脸砸烂。然后我要扔一块石头在他的车上。来吧，我们现在去纽约。我开车。如果我不戴眼镜撞到他，我不认为这是犯罪。太棒了。
God, I should have told you this sooner. What a jerk. What a jerk. Can you imagine if they had left in the sex talk between Jim and Pam up at the top? And then this scene of Pam saying she's going to throw a rock at Ryan or maybe hit him with her car. Oh, my gosh. And in the shooting draft, it was much shorter. said, I'm going to smash his face. And that was it, you know. But in this deleted scene, Pam is going
天哪，我应该早点告诉你这个。真是个混蛋。你能想象如果他们留下了吉姆和帕姆在顶部的性谈话吗？然后是帕姆说她要扔一块石头在瑞安身上，或者也许用她的车撞他的场景。哦，天哪。在拍摄剧本里，它短得多。说，我要砸烂他的脸。就是这样，你知道。但在这个删减片段里，帕姆要
off. You do not mess with her man. I guess not. Not after the night they had last night. The one night in heaven? Yeah. Wowsers. Well, the tag for this episode brings us all the resolution we need. We're back in the conference room. Michael is proposing some more great ideas like a summer Christmas caroling sales event. He throws to Stanley. Stanley, what do you think? Stanley says, I think it might be your best idea yet. Yeah.
走了。你不要惹她的男人。我想不是。不是在他们昨晚度过的那个夜晚之后。那个在天堂的一夜？是的。哇。好吧，这一集的标签带给我们所有我们需要的分辨率。我们回到会议室。迈克尔正在提出一些更伟大的想法，比如夏季圣诞颂歌销售活动。他扔给斯坦利。斯坦利，你怎么看？斯坦利说，我认为这可能是你迄今为止最好的主意。是的。
And then Phyllis kind of laughs and says, that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard. Michael says, everybody out except Phyllis. Episode. It's such a great tag. Guys, that was Did I Stutter. I can't believe I'm about to say this, Angela. We are coming up on.
然后菲利斯有点笑，说，那是我听过的最愚蠢的事情。迈克尔说，每个人都出去，除了菲利斯。剧集。这是一个很棒的标签。伙计们，那是“我结巴了吗”。我不敢相信我要说这个，安吉拉。我们即将到来。
On the end of season four, we've just got a few more episodes. I know. Last night, I had to put a whole new disc in my DVD player. Wow. You know it's serious when she's got to put a new disc in, guys. Yeah, I'm on my last disc for season four. It's going by so fast. It's flying by.
在第四季结束时，我们只有几集了。我知道。昨晚，我不得不把一张全新的光盘放进我的DVD播放机。哇。你知道当她不得不放一张新光盘时，情况很严重，伙计们。是的，我在第四季的最后一张光盘上。它过得太快了。它飞逝而过。
We'll be back next week with Job Fair. Thank you to Brent Forrester and to Leslie David Baker. Thanks for texting us back about this episode. And thanks to me for being a digital whole. order and having my shooting draft. Yes, thank you, Angela. All right, you guys. Have a great week.
我们下周会回来，带着“招聘会”。感谢布伦特·福雷斯特和莱斯利·大卫·贝克。谢谢你发短信回复我们关于这一集。也感谢我作为一个数字囤积者，拥有我的拍摄剧本。是的，谢谢你，安吉拉。好了，你们。祝你们有愉快的一周。
We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins. And our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
我们下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。“办公室女士”是Odyssey的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯。我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。